so cold outside you definitely want to
do everything to kind of keep yourself
warm yeah 65 that's two that's too
chilly for me
right am i right yes guilty yeah that's
probably what my bill is like huge
i need warm
70. i need 70s i keep it cool do you
really oh yeah where do you keep yours
at i'm more or less about like 66 i like
it nice and cool do you have icicles in
your house
i'm just kidding i have a lot of
blankets
great great job on that story christian
that's some great advice there too uh
outside right now clear skies
winds a lot better than yesterday
remember we had those very strong winds
that was going to be our big wind day
today a little breezy and that's we're
seeing outside right now got new flow
facts to show you okay i got this from
our good friends at the national weather
service 32 degrees this morning guys
that's what we hit that makes this the
sixth time las vegas has hit freezing
this winter season six times already
this is the most freezes in the winter
season since to the
2015-2016 season where we hit freezing
up 10 times all right wow currently
outside right now 54 degrees sky canyon
and same for centennial hills 55 north
las vegas the east side coming in at 55
double fives also for whitney ranch
mountains edge 51 anthem you're at 51
along with henderson and southern
highlands right now regional
temperatures even chillier for you
indian springs only at 49 degrees 52
boulder city and 53 for sandy valley
right now all the weather alerts were
allowed to expire that wind advisory
expired at four o'clock right now we
have one that's the hard freeze warning
again for you in kingman dolan springs
area mohave county that's because your
temperatures are going to drop around 20
to 25 in the morning all right early
early on this morning we're talking
maybe the five six a.m hours when it
will dip down and before those numbers
start to go up one of the reasons why
temperatures have been so chilly lately
is because we're just on the western
fringe of this trough here and within
this is the colder air you can see that
all changing over to snow within that
over towards the midwest there wind
forecast does show
the winds will decrease more tonight
that's good right but then friday
we should stay light for those winds but
then we'll see them pick up a little bit
more again for saturday but we will have
warmer temperatures for your weekend
here you go 56 for friday saturday 62 64
on sunday so yeah this puts us a little
bit near normal for this time of year
but we'll see those winds pick up a
little more especially on sunday
overnight lows back again dropping to
near freezing for a lot of our
neighborhoods areas that will drop below
freezing summerlin
and same for anthem possibly out in the
outskirts of henderson there 31 for
prompt 32 boulder city freezing mark for
you 34 overnight very chilly and clear
expect light breezes your high tomorrow
56 sunny and cool tomorrow but still
below normal but we'll get there we'll
get there this weekend remember we've
got the pro bowl we've got the nhl
all-stars all here this weekend i'll
have a better look at that forecast
coming up but look at the temperatures
next week we could reach 70 degrees as
early as tuesday back to you